ce week end vous avez peut être croisé
d'hommes beau tintin et milou winnie
l'ourson rien de plus normal c'est proue
de radeaux attendent le défilé de jour
de chair des embarcations mise au point
depuis plusieurs semaines aujourd'hui
prête pour la fête et parmi des bateaux
celui des super héros à 9 9 à 19,1 du
week-end de construction de tout papier
mâché soit hulk de 2050 c'est notre
journée les enfants ils sont gardés par
les papys et mamies et là c'est vraiment
notre journée à nous plus adulte un peu
plus loin des habitués de jours de chair
quatre amis qui ont choisi cette année
l'ouest des états unis bande de copains
de civray de touraine voilà tous voisins
tous copains et là on s'éclate bords du
cher sur le cher dans l'os bhl qui ce
blond presque
au fil de l'eau des écluses et des
guinguettes le cheikh rassemble une
itinérance festive entre blairer et
saint georges qui met en lumière le
patrimoine exceptionnel avec lequel les
habitants de la vallée entretiennent une
relation particulière et ya deux jours
j'allais faire du canoë sur le cher ça
fait un peu rond c'est pas la plage
c'est pas la mer mais
voilà on va sur le port du fier on va
sur l'eau ça fait plaisir quand il fait
beau comme ça c'est super agréable ainsi
perdu pour faire du sport mais pour
aller courir pour se promener
boire un coup à la guinguette pour
écouter la dans le cher à vélo c'est
magnifique les gens sont heureux c'est
très très bien ce cher et c'est un
bonheur de l'avoir parfois la pêche pour
sortir les enfants un peu de canoë de
temps un temps et puis les balades
surtout c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
endroit nature sympa on en profite au
maximum on a la chance d'habiter ici
donc c'est vrai que c'est chouette un
festival sur l'eau et à terre avec ses
concerts pour lequel les visiteurs ont
voté pour le plus beau raddho